مره اخرى تخرق السلطات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي كل التفاهمات السياسيه ففي
واضح النهار اقتحمت مخيم عقبه جابر في
اريحا قوه مستعربين تسللت بسياره فلسطينيه
مدعومه بحشد من جنود واليات الاحتلال
حاصروا منزلا اصابوا فلسطينيين بالرصاص
اعتقلوا عددا اخر
واحتجزوا ابا وطفله كدرع بشري بعدها
انسحبت قوات الاحتلال من داخل المخيم
متلقيه تهاني وزير الدفاع ومبقيه حواجز
عسكريه تطوق المحافظه
اما في حوار الجنوبيه نابلس فابقى
الاحتلال حصاره العسكري عليها منذ الاحد
الماضي حواره التي صرح زعيم الصهيونيه
الدينيه بوجوب محوها من الوجود
يجب محو قريه حوار من الارض على اسرائيل
القيام بذلك وليس المدنيين
رئيس الحكومه الفلسطينيه زار مع وفدا من
الوزراء البلده وصف ما وقع فيها الاحد
الماضي بالجريمه اسرائيل الان تريد اعاده
انتاج النكب سواء كان على شكل مذابح او
سواء كان على شكل تهجير او غيره لذلك
رسالتنا واضحه لا نكرر ما جرى في التاريخ
احنا موجودين هون على ارضنا صامدين
اما الحصار العسكري المتواصل لقريه ضمن
قرى تربط شمال الضفه الغربيه بوسطها فكبد
الاهالي خسائر ماليه فادحه وانسانيه صعبه
مرت معها سرطان دور مش قادر اجيبها الدور
يعني ما يخلف على رئيس البلديه عبالي مي
بصعوبه وصلته اعطاني عبالي مي يعني الوضع
عندنا نعسان ماساه ماساه ماساه طلعناه طلع
المستوطنين طلع الجيش على راسي عليهم
مشاهدوا دفعت مؤسسات وفعاليات الى التحذير
مما هو قادم نحن مقبلين على مجازر ومحارق
قادمه لا محاله المستوطنين حملوا السلاح
باذن من حكومتهم ووزعوا السلاح وهم
ارهابيين مدربون يساعد الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي عمليات القتل والحرق والتدمير
والتهجير ويمارس اجراءات انتقاميه بحق
الاسرى ويفرض عقوبات جماعيه ويرى
الفلسطينيون في الاجراءات الاسرائيليه
جرائم مكتمله بغطاء سياسيا وامنيا من
الحكومه الاسرائيليه اليمينيه جفال
الجزيره من بلده حواره جنوبينابلس